good morning John it is Halloween and
the last thing I need is an excuse to
put stuff on my head these are funny I
don't think they're made for men these
aren't really men horns they're kind of
extra fuzzy okay put them like this oh
oh oh just like that rest of my glasses
perfect perfect Halloween is a very nerd
firely day as far as I'm concerned I
mean it's not like we need an excuse to
you know be weird frankly I think that
we should do it every day but it
occurred to me recently that I was
really gonna be able to participate in
Halloween because I'm packing so that we
can begin the nerdfighter tour very very
soon so yeah I'm not going to any
Halloween parties we are giving out
candy but that's pretty much the extent
of our Halloween activities but it did
occur to me that it's quite obvious what
I should be for Halloween and that is of
course Edward spoon hands and if you
don't know what I'm talking about and
that's just too bad
you will soon like now Edward and Edwina
spoon hands I have a pretty hard time of
it they can hardly eat cereal and they
can only type about three words a minute
but they both agree it's not as bad as
it could be so they clock their big old
fingers and they sing a little song for
you and me Edward and Edwina spoon hands
I have a pretty hard time of it they can
hardly cereal and they can only type
about three words a minute but they both
the Creed's not as bad as it could be so
they clack their big old fingers and
they sing a little song for you and me
Edward that we
very hard time of it they can hardly eat
cereal they can only die about three
words
they both agreed not as bad as it could
be so they pack their big ol finger
then they sang a little song for you and
me Edward that weenus blue hand
very hard job
they can hardly see Rio they can only
type by three men but a boat
[Music]
so they pack their big old finger
amazing little song for you it be
[Music]
and worden Edwina spoon hands out a very
hard time of it
they can hardly see Rio they can only
talk about three words
they both the
as bad as it could be so big back there
big open
[Music]
nerdfighters John I will see you I'll
see you too
well I'll see you tomorrow like in the
airport crazy
whoo tour begins
I don't know what this looks like cuz I
can see the thing but to me it's kind of
like Geordi LaForge but with horns
instead of you know sight vision goggles